Hello, everyone, and welcome
to lecture 7 of CME 286.
So today is a very
exciting day because we'll
be talking about how to evaluate
the quality of the output
of the text-to-image
generation models
that we've been seeing so far.
And in particular, if you
think about it, in order
for you to know what
to improve, you first
need to know how
good your output is.
So that's why this lecture is
going to be quite important.
But before we start,
as usual, we're
going to recap what
we saw last time.
So if you remember,
last time we focused
on the training lifecycle of
text-to-image generation models.
And we first started
by focusing on the loss
that we're using for training,
and in particular, we
looked at the time step
t that up until then
we assume to be drawn from
a uniform distribution.
And we saw that it was actually
not fair to treat all time
steps equally.
And we saw that there
was a distribution that
was quite nice in
this case, which
was the logit normal
distribution, which emphasized
on the middle steps,
which are harder
to learn compared to the
earlier and the later steps.
And this is mainly because
early on, you have basically
no information on which for
you to base your prediction,
so you just predict the mean of
where all the observations are.
And then towards the
end, you have almost
denoised your whole
image, but in the middle,
you're figuring out where
to go and how you want
to take those big decisions.
So we not only saw
this, but we also
saw that for a given noise
level, if you have a higher
resolution image,
then you perceived
noise is going to be less than
a lower resolution image, which
is the reason why you need to
do what we call a timeout step
shift.
And we saw this formula, which
hopefully is not that haunting
right now, which
is something that
is derived by our
uncertainty of what
the underlying pixel value is.
And then what we did was go
through the whole training life
cycle of text-to-image
generation models,
and we started
with pre-training,
where our goal was to teach our
model how to generate images.
So we saw curriculum
learning, where
the goal was to teach
our model first,
how to do the easy things
before doing the harder things.
And then what we
did was also look
at how we can handle
different resolutions.
And we saw that given that
we have a DIT-based model,
it's only a matter
of having a longer
input at the end of the day.
Then we looked at
post-training approaches
aimed at getting you to
generate more beautiful images.
And here, we saw
two main strategies
on the supervised side, which
was continued training, focusing
on acquiring more
knowledge, which
is more relevant to the domain
you want to use your model.
And then supervised
fine tuning, which
is aimed at just improving
the aesthetics of the images
that you produce.
And we also saw some
preference tuning methods,
which were aimed at capturing
negative user signals because up
until then, we only taught
our model what to do,
but not what to not do.
So this is the goal of
techniques that are derived
from JRPO, DPO, and so on.
And after that, we saw how
we could personalize our text
to image generation model.
And we looked at DreamBooth,
which is one such method, which
aims at relying on a
rare token and training
your model on the
specific object or person
that you want to
capture, and then
use that tuned model
at inference time
to be able to leverage what you
have learned at training time.
And then finally, we saw a range
of distillation methods, which
were aimed at shortening
the number of steps that
were needed at
inference time, so we
saw progressive distillation.
We saw distribution matching
distillation, and here we are.
Today, we're going to
focus on evaluation,
which as I mentioned,
is going to be
about assessing how
good of a quality
the output generated image is.
So as you can maybe
think, judging
of the quality of an image
can be quite subjective,
so I want us to start
with a motivating example.
And I would like to ask
you, based on an input
prompt that I'm going to
read, which hopefully,
is familiar by now, whether you
think that image is a good image
or not.
So the input prompt is a
teddy bear reading a book.
And here is the generated image.
So the question is, do you
think that this generated
image is a good, or bad output?
So who says good?
Who says bad?
We agree it's an output that
is not very pleasing to see,
and the main reason
here is well,
the aesthetics are not great.
You look at the image,
it doesn't look great.
OK, so how about this one?
Do you think that this
image is a good image?
Who says it's a good image?
Bad image?
Yeah, so why is it a bad image?
Yeah, so it's indeed not
representing the prompt.
I agree with you,
so it's something
that we call prompt
adherence, where
we want the output to follow
what we have it as input.
And so here, although this
image is great to look at,
well, it's not about a
teddy bear reading a book.
Last one.
Is this image a
good image or not?
So who says good image?
Bad image?
So why is it a bad image?
So you have a very refined
taste, which is great.
So let's suppose that this
images is good enough for us
because here, first it's
following the prompt,
so it's a teddy
bear reading a book.
And then second, let's say it's
more aesthetically pleasing
compared to the other ones.
So from this small
scale exercise,
what I wanted to point
out was that when
we look at the outputs of a
text-to-image generation model,
we typically look at things with
respect to two main buckets.
Not exhaustive, but
two main buckets.
The first one is, if you
take this picture on its own,
does this look like
a good picture?
An aesthetically
pleasing picture?
So here, you think
about whether what
is in there is
physically plausible.
So for instance, if the book
that your teddy bear is reading
is on the table
and not floating,
if it's realistic, if a
perceptual quality is there.
And then the second
big bucket is
whether the produced output is
indeed following your inputs.
So here, it's called
prompt adherence.
And what we want to see is
whether the objects, the people,
the locations are indeed
present in the image,
and we want the image
to be of a given style.
And if, for
instance, I say, it's
reading a book about
the CME 296 class,
I want CME 296 to be on
the book, so all of that
would be within that bucket.
But I mentioned that these two
categories are not exhaustive.
Of course, you have a
bunch of other criteria
that you can think of,
so I'll just name a few.
So the first one
is safety, so you
want to make sure you're not
depicting things that are
interpreted in a unsafe way.
You want to make sure that
if you generate something
based on a prompt,
you're not always
generating the same thing,
so you want something
that is a bit diverse.
You don't want to memorize
the things that you
have seen as inputs,
and so here, it's
trying to have
some generalization
capabilities for your model.
And then you have a bunch
of other dimensions,
so here, for instance, the bias.
You don't want your
model to always output
the same outputs, which could
be, again, misinterpreted.
So for all these
reasons, what I propose
is that this image
evaluation problem,
we can think of it as us trying
to think if the image that we're
getting as output is
mainly good along these two
dimensions, which are
aesthetics and prompt adherence.
So let's assume that these are
our two main categories that we
care about.
And with that, I
would like to start
with a very simple and natural
way of evaluating your output,
which is to leverage humans.
So here, the idea is
you have your model, you
have some input prompt that
is having your model generate
an image, and what
you're saying is OK,
given this prompt,
given this image,
how would you rate this image?
So here, one possible option
is to have a scale from 1 to 5,
where 1 is very bad
and 5 is very good.
And the idea is to figure out
where your image falls into.
So in this case, let's
assume it's very good.
Then what you would
do is in order
to measure the performance of
your model across a data set,
you would take the
average of the ratings,
so you would do
sum of the ratings,
over the number
of ratings, which
you can call average rating.
So the good thing
with this score
is it is nuanced,
because you have a way
to distinguish a very good image
versus a good image, but not
a great image and so on.
But the main drawback
there is, given
that you're letting
more degrees of freedom
for humans to decide on which
rating that is, it can introduce
some noise in the ratings that
you're getting, because humans
may think that an image is a 5,
but someone else can think it's
a 4.
Someone else can
think it's a three.
So everyone has their own way
of interpreting the scale,
and so this can introduce
some noise in the ratings.
And also, if you think about
it for a lot of problems,
it's actually very
hard as a person
to say if something
is a 4 versus a 5.
It's just a hard problem.
And so for that
reason, a second method
of digging into this issue
is instead of having a 1 to 5
scale, to reduce this problem
into a binary problem, which
is much easier for
humans to handle,
because here, you
are given an image,
and you just need to say
whether it's good or bad.
So here, we assume that
the answer is good.
And so the score that we
can think of in this setting
is, again, taking the
sum of the ratings,
over the number of ratings.
And here, it would
be the pass rate.
So how many of your
images are what
is the proportion
of your images that
is actually passing the bar?
So the good thing here
is, it is an easier
task for humans to
work on, so the ratings
are less noisy in that sense.
But one problem is humans,
although it's on a binary scale,
they have a hard time evaluating
things on an absolute scale.
So it's easier for
you to, let's say,
compare two things,
as opposed to saying
whether that something
is passing the bar
or not because you need
to have some reference.
So for that reason, I want
to propose a third method
of going about doing this,
which is trying to rate
those images by comparing
them to some other images.
So here, it's the pairwise
comparison setting.
And the setup would be you
have your input prompts,
and what you do is you
generate two images.
And your task is to say
which one of these images
is better than the other one?
So do you agree with me
that this task is easier
than the absolute scale task?
So in this case, you agree
that the left one is a better
image than the right one?
So I'm glad you said
no for the other one,
because this illustrates the
point that on an absolute scale,
people have different
expectations.
So they may think that the left
one may not be above the bar,
but when you compare
these two images,
it is just obvious
that the left one
is better than the right one.
And so in that sense, the
ratings that you're getting
are going to be even less noisy
compared to the absolute scale,
binary one.
So how about the metric?
So very naively,
a very natural way
would be to just, for a given
model, count the number of wins,
and divide it by the
number of times it
was compared to something else.
So this one is the win rate.
Do you think that's
a good metric?
So here, what we're
doing is for each model,
we're generating
outputs, and we're
comparing these
outputs to, let's
say, outputs of another model.
What we're saying is,
in order to quantify
the performance of that
first model, the model a,
what we're doing
is, we're counting
the number of times images
produced by this model won
over the opponent,
and we divide that
by the number of comparisons.
So the question is,
do you think that is
a good way of doing things?
So the answer is, so for one
reference OK, but for many
not sure.
Well, you have the
right intuition here.
So what I want to
say here is winning
against a model
that is known to be
excellent is much harder than
winning against a model that
is known to be bad.
So our intuition here
is your win proportion
should not be the
only factor here.
You should also consider who
you are comparing yourself with,
and it's exactly
what you mentioned.
And I'm not sure
if you're tracking
the performance of
text-to-image generation models,
but typically, you have
something like this.
You have a leaderboard, where
you have models that are ranked.
And one challenge
with this setting
is that models they come,
but also they can go.
So when a model
comes, let's suppose
you want to have
a win rate that is
reflective of the
performance of that model,
you will need to have
the same model be
evaluated against all
models of that list.
And you want all
models of that list
to be also evaluated against
all other models of that list
every time the
list gets updated,
so this is a lot of evaluations.
So you don't want to always
have to evaluate everyone
against everyone every
time something gets
updated on the list to
make things apple to apple.
So for that reason, well,
something that we can think of
is to adjust that
win rate metric
by taking into consideration
how strong your opponent is
within the metric.
So how do we want to do that?
Well, before we go
into exactly how we
do that, I just want
to illustrate the point
I mentioned.
So here, let's imagine we have
our model, let's say model A,
that we want to evaluate
against other models.
Well, if our model wins
against a bad model,
your reaction is
OK, and so what?
You already that it's better
than that very basic model,
so there's nothing to
be surprised about.
But if the human says
your model is winning
against another model that
is much, much stronger,
then your reaction
will be different.
So the idea is to capture
that within the metric,
so let's see how
we want to do that.
So first of all, let's assume
that we have a metric per model
that we note R. R as in rating.
And let's assume that our model,
model A starts with a rating
of, let's say, 1,000.
And we're a newcomer,
and in that leaderboard,
it just happens that
there is a model,
let's suppose it's a bad model,
that has a worse rating, which
is 600, let's say.
So let's have our model A be
compared against that bad model.
How would we want
to update the score?
So one idea could be
to compute the score
that we think would happen,
if those models that perform
like they did in the past.
So let's compute
the expected score,
and for that, let's just
use this formula, which
gives us the expected score.
And so here the formula
would be 1 over 1
plus 10 to the power of
the rating of the model
that you're competing
against, minus your rating,
over some arbitrary constants.
And let's assume
that constant is 400.
Then this quantity would be
your expected winning chance.
And so here, it's 0.9,
so 90% chance of winning.
So now that you have your
baseline, what you want to do
is compute your actual score.
So actually, compare
the two models.
So here, the outcome can
be one of three things,
so you can either lose, be
tied, or win over the bad model.
And the idea is to use
these two quantities, so
the expected score
and the actual score
to compute your
element of surprise,
how much you went above,
or how much you went below.
And here, it would be delta
equal to the actual score
that you obtained,
minus the score
that you think you would
have obtained on average.
And here, in this case, if model
A wins, it would be plus 0.1.
If it loses, then
it's minus 0.9,
and if there's a tie it's
also a minus, minus 0.4.
So here, by the way, the numbers
they just come from this formula
that we just plug
the ratings into that
and then we compute delta.
So the good thing
with this observation
is we see that if we have our
model win against the bad model,
well, there is not a
lot of gains, which
is aligned with our intuition.
And if the model loses, then it
means it's really, really bad,
so there is a big
downward contribution.
And even if there
is a tie, we know
that if we're tied
with a very bad model,
then that's also a bad
contribution for our rating,
so the first step would be to
just update our rating by adding
k times delta.
So that would be the recipe.
And so the image that I
showed you a few slides ago
was actually this slide, where
I masked the middle columns.
So this is how the
leaderboards do it.
In practice, they
compute the score.
So maybe you may have
heard this score.
It's called the
Elo rating, and it
allows you to track the
performance of a model
by computing the score
as a function of how
strong your opponent is.
And this allows you to avoid
having everyone be evaluated
against everyone
every time there
is a change in who's
in the leaderboard.
And by the way, Elo
is actually the name
of the person who came
up with the method.
It's not an acronym.
So that's good to note.
But what are the problems
with this approach?
Well, every time we want
to evaluate our model,
if we had to always
involve humans,
well, it will be a
very expensive task.
So that's the first limitation.
Also, humans, there's
only 24 hours in a day.
It's a slow method.
It can also be
subjective, so the example
that we had in
the very beginning
is one example of that.
Another example can
be try to tell me
if this image is well lit.
There are several notions
of something being well lit.
So again, it's a subjective
task, so answers can differ.
And, of course, humans
are not perfect either.
Depending on the
time of the day,
you may have external
circumstances
that may also influence on
the quality of your ratings.
So all of that is I
hope, a motivation for us
to look at automated metrics
that would allow us to quantify
how good the outputs are.
And we're going
to start with what
we call reference-free
metrics, and I'm
going to tell you in a second
what reference-free means.
So as I mentioned, we're in the
text to image generation case.
We have a text as
input and we have
a model that produces an image.
So one thing that I want to
tell you is there are they're
just multiple ways
you can produce
an image for a same
prompt like these ones.
And for that reason, having
a single image as reference
is a little bit unfair
because you would always
try to compare against
that same reference.
That is not the only
way you can do things,
and so for that reasons, the
metrics that we're going to see
are called reference-free,
as in they're not
using a single output
reference image as reference.
They're not doing that.
So that's the reference-free.
And so let's go
back to our problem.
And so here, we have an
input, which is a text prompt,
and then we have
an image as output.
And I told you we could
consider our problem
as being us trying to
quantify how good the image is
with respect to aesthetics
and with respect
to prompt adherence.
Well, here, let's
start with aesthetics.
And let's take our
generated image,
which is on the right and our
real image that is on the left.
So as I mentioned,
it is not fair
for us to compare our generated
image with a single reference.
So one idea can be to actually
take many generated images
and many real images.
And instead of comparing
your single generated image
to the single real
image, one idea
could be to look at the
distribution of both
and see how the two compares.
So let's do that.
Well, how would you do it?
Well, in the class,
we've seen that we
have methods to represent images
in what we call a latent space,
or some space.
So here, one idea could be to
take our, let's say, real images
and have them be inputs
into some encoder such
that they can be
represented in space.
So we can do that with
the sets of real images.
And in parallel, we can also
take our generated images,
and also let them through
that pre-trained encoder
so that they can also be
represented in that same space.
So the idea that
we can have here
is to try to compare
how these two resulting
distributions in this space,
how these two compare.
So in order to characterize
each distribution,
you can have the mean, mu,
and the covariance matrix
sigma that can just tell you
about how your distribution is
shaped.
And what you want to do
is to compare the two.
So you want to compare
where they are located,
so here, you can use the
mean, and how they are shaped,
you can use the
covariance sigma.
So the covariance
matrix is a quantity
that tells you how spread
out your distribution is,
and also what are the
directions of that spread.
So by the way, why
would you also want
to quantify the spread?
Well, you also want your
generated images to be diverse,
and so here, the spread will be
around quantifying how diverse
your generated images are.
And so, as I
mentioned, what we want
is to quantify the distance
between these two distributions.
And so we can come up
with some formula, which
I'm putting it on the slide.
And we're going to go
through each component, where
the first term is
around quantifying
the difference in where these
distributions are located,
so comparing the means
of each distribution,
and also comparing the shape
of each of these distributions.
So here, so Tr stands
for trace, so it's
an operation on a matrix.
And maybe it's the first time
you're seeing this formula,
your first reaction
may be, well,
where do you have this formula?
What does it represent?
So the truth is this metric,
which is called the Fréchet
Inception Distance,
is a metric that
is derived from a distance
that is called the Wasserstein
distance that aims at
quantifying how much effort you
would have to do to go from one
distribution to another one.
And it just turns
out that if you
assume that the
distribution of real images
and the distribution
of generated images,
they are each Gaussian.
If you assume that,
then it just happens
that this Wasserstein
distance, which
is something that typically does
not have a closed form solution,
is something that you can
express in a closed form.
So that's where the
formula comes from.
But in terms of
interpreting each term,
you can think of the first term
as being the difference in terms
of location, and the second
one is how the shapes differ.
Cool.
So it's a distance, so what
you want is those distances
to be as small as possible.
So the lower your
FID, the better it is.
So the question is, can
you use VLM to do that?
So we're going to see that
later in this lecture.
So the question is, can
you say a little bit
about how to
interpret these terms
and how this relates to
these [INAUDIBLE] Gaussians?
So we're not going
to go into that,
but the underlying
idea behind this metric
is to quantify how much effort
you would have to transport
one distribution to another.
And this is, you can think
of it as some formula
that has this interpretation.
And what I was saying was,
if you assume that the shape,
or that your real
image distribution,
and if you assume that your
generated image distribution,
if you assume that each
of them is Gaussian,
then what we're saying is that
the quantity that I mentioned
can actually be computed with
a rather nice formula that
is closed form.
So this goes into the broader
theme of Gaussian distributions,
just simplifying
a lot of things,
and this is one of
those instances.
So the question is the
real here is the data?
Yes, so you would take a set of
real images, so non-generated
images, and you would
compute their representation
using the pre-trained encoder.
And you would use
those representations
to represent those real images.
So the question is, can
I use it in pixel space?
So here's the thing.
This metric is there for you to
compare how well your model is
doing compared to
other models out there,
so you need to have some
space that is the same as what
the other ones have mentioned.
And so here this metric is
called Fréchet Inception
Distance because actually
the pre-trained encoder is
the Inception network.
And so what you want is, if
you want to compare yourself
with someone else,
you necessarily
need to take the
same representation
to make things comparable.
So the question is if your
diffusion model is pixel space,
is this still applicable?
Yes, so what you would do is you
have your real images that you
go through a pre-trained model.
Your Pixel space
diffusion, no problem.
You do your diffusion in
pixel space and at the end,
you get those generated
images and you input them
into that Inception model.
And then you have
your representation.
Oh, yeah.
Good question.
So the question is,
are these conditioned
on a particular prompt?
So it's a great question.
Well, you touch a
great point, which
is that you want your
model to perform well
on what you care about.
So, for instance, you
may care about generating
faces, let's say, or generating
some nature, some indoor scenes.
So depending on
what your task is,
you may want to compare your
generated images with respect
to a set of real images that
are representative of the thing
that you care about.
So you have a
number of data sets
like ImageNet is
one that's quite--
it's a classic one.
And then you have, I
believe, MS COCO, and so on.
And so you can
think of the images
that you generate
as being conditioned
by a set of prompts
that are going
to match what is there, so it
can be either captions, or class
conditions.
So you have something that
allows you to compare yourself
to that distribution.
And typically, you
would use a data
set that is aligned with
your task of interest,
and that data set would
contain the thing that you
would use as inputs.
Great question.
So the question is,
in practice, how large
is the set of real
images that you take?
So typically, 50k.
And actually, speaking of
that, we've seen in lecture 5,
I'm not sure if you
remember, we had DIT,
which measured its performance
on that FID 50k scale.
So 50k here means that we have
a set of 50,000 real images.
So here, what you would do is
generate 50,000 generated images
and compare that distribution
with the set of 50,000 real
images.
But I've also seen 30,000.
Typically, in the order
of tens of thousands.
So the question is, is it
fair to use variance and mean
to characterize the
whole distribution?
Is that roughly your--
oh yeah.
So the question is,
is it fair to assume
that the shape and the distance
is representative of quality?
So it's a great question.
Actually, one funny thing is,
if you look at social media,
I would say, every week, you
would see a new paper coming up
with a new metric.
So this metric is by far
not a perfect metric,
and the community voices
that out, for sure.
So yeah, I agree with you.
It is not necessarily
indicative of the quality
that you want to reach, but
it's a good enough proxy,
or, at least, that's what
the community thinks.
And I would say, so
it's a personal take.
One of the reasons why it's
been hard to change the metric
that people use is because when
you want to publish a paper,
typically you want to show
that your method is good,
so you want to compare yourself
to some previous method.
And its people have
just been using FID.
So that's why it's really
hard to change from that.
But I agree with your
point, which it is not
necessarily reflective of
the quality of your images,
which is why in
papers, you would also
see a bunch cherry picked or
not cherry picked images that
are shown in the paper just
to show how good the model is.
Cool.
Great.
So I'm looking at the time.
I will move ahead, and
just say that if there's
a big gap in the
location, you can
think of it as maybe the quality
or the style being different.
And when it comes to the
shape being different,
for instance, the
generated images
is in a very constrained
region, maybe
your model is not
generating diverse sets.
So these are the points
to watch out for.
And in terms of the sample
size, so as we mentioned,
the typical reference is
FID-50k of a given data set.
And, of course, so
we're looking at FID,
which is part of this section
of reference-free metrics,
and here we're using a
reference distribution.
So I know that it
may sound confusing,
but I just want you to
know that reference-free,
the title of this
section, refers
to us not comparing one
generated output with one
real image.
It is more about comparing
the distribution.
And then the last thing is, one
of the main complaints of people
is that the distribution of real
images and the distribution of
generated images, they are
typically not Gaussian,
so this formula is
typically not 100% valid.
So the question is this
formula only for Gaussians?
So the formula is
actually derived
from this other quantity that's
called the Wasserstein distance.
And so this formula
is specifically
when you compare two
distributions that
are Gaussians.
And so that's
another limitation,
and a point that you will see
in papers when they're OK,
FID is not that
great of a metric.
Cool, so this is the aesthetics.
So FID is the metric that most
people use, for better or worse,
to quantify how
good of a quality
your generated images are.
And second, as
previously mentioned,
we're going to look
at prompt adherence.
How can we, or how
can we quantify
that the output image
that we're getting
is aligned with the input?
And so for this,
actually, you may
have in mind a method we
saw in lecture 4 CLIP, which
stands for Contrastive
Language-Image
Pre-training, which aimed at
comparing the text and an image
by encoding each separately
through their respective
encoders and training the
resulting system using
a contrastive loss that
incentivizes elements that are
similar to have a higher score,
and elements that are not
similar to have a lower score.
So you could very
well use that model,
where you would put
the input text that you
use to generate the image
along with the generated image.
And there is a model out there
that's called the CLIP score.
That is actually
exactly that CLIP model,
that allows you to get an actual
score in terms of how aligned
your text and your image are.
That's called the CLIP score.
And speaking of taking into
consideration both the prompt
and the image, you can
also think of doing so
using a CLIP like model.
Not in order to predict how
aligned the two are, but maybe
to align, or maybe
to predict how good
the image is to the input text.
So you could very
well take such a model
and train it on a data set that
is around human preferences,
and that's what people did.
So this is the PickScore.
So what they did was
they took a CLIP model
and they trained it
on preference data,
where you had image and text and
the label was the preference.
And here, you can
get a PickScore,
which is a holistic
score that combines
both the aesthetics and
the prompt adherence,
along with some other
things to tell you
about the overall satisfaction
of the human with respect
to the generated output.
So this is the last metric I
wanted to talk to you about.
Now, I want us to
take a step back.
When we talk about evaluation,
we may think about the image
generation model, but as we saw,
it's not actually the only model
we're interested in.
We've also seen other
pieces that do matter.
For instance, the
VAE, which is tasked
with reconstructing the input.
And in this setting, well, your
label is much, much clearer
because what you want
to do, your proxy task
is to reconstruct
the original input.
And so in that sense,
you do have a reference
to base yourself on,
so you could very well,
in this setting, want to compare
what you output with what
you want it to output.
And this is the reason
why in this section,
we're going to go through such
metrics, which we're calling
reference-based as
opposed to reference-free,
because reference-based
metrics have something
that you can use to compare
your generated image against.
So I mentioned the VAE, but you
have actually other use cases
as well.
So we've not really gone
into details about text image
to image tasks, so image
editing tasks, but you
may also want to compare
how your edited image is
with respect to the
input image, to make
sure you're
controlling for things
that you don't want
to edit, and so on.
So this is not
just something that
is valid for VAEs, but for
other use cases as well.
Cool, so just getting a bit more
rigorous about our notations.
So the input is noted x.
The outputs, which is an attempt
at reconstructing the input
is called, or is noted x hat.
And what you want is to
have a quantified metric
to compare the two
that hopefully,
will align with the quality
of your reconstruction.
So the first metric that
you may think about,
I mean, the formula looks
scary, but it's just
about comparing pixels--
just pixel-wise distance.
And you may also that distance
under the name MSE, which
stands for Mean Squared Error.
And so this metric, what it does
is it takes these two images
and it just computes the
pixel-wise distance of a given
pixel in the reference
image and the pixel
in your generated image.
And it does that for all pixels.
And one big drawback is it
is very sensitive to exactly
the alignment between
these two images,
and so if you have generated
a perfect reconstruction,
but that is slightly
shifted a few pixels,
let's say to the
right, then your MSC
will be actually terrible.
So that's one drawback.
The second drawback is if
we tell you about an MSC,
let's say it's 10, I don't know.
Well, you don't what
to do with that number
because it depends how
you encode your pixels.
So sometimes it is
between 0 and 1.
Sometimes it is
between 0 and 255.
The scale varies,
which is the reason why
you have another metric
that is still pixel-wise
that is called the Peak
Signal-to-Noise Ratio, PSNR,
which normalizes MSE with
respect to the maximum value
that it can take.
So this allows you to, at
least, get a reference,
or put things into context.
So it not only does that,
it also wraps the thing
into a logarithm.
And I just want to pause here
for a second with an analogy
that to me makes a lot of sense,
and I hope it will make sense
to you as well.
So if we're in a room, where
there is absolutely no light,
and if I just turn on
one light bulb, to you,
the difference between
the complete darkness
and one light bulb is a lot.
But if in this room we have all
these light bulbs already on,
and if I turn on yet
another light bulb,
the perceptual difference
between having that extra light
bulb in this setting
and the one light
bulb that is turned on versus
darkness is very different.
So this is what this
log tries to do, so if--
you almost don't
have any errors.
It's very, very small value.
And you have just a
little bit more error.
From your perspective,
it will be more something
that you would want to notice
in terms of the variation,
as opposed to if you have an
image that is quite wrong,
that is yet again, a little bit
more wrong with the same delta.
So this is what the
logarithm tries to do.
Well, it's great,
but it is still
subject to this
pixel position, so it
is sensitive to any shifting.
And this is the reason why
these are not the only metrics
that people use.
And in particular,
there is one metric
that you may see in
papers that looks at how
these images are structured.
So let me tell you a little
bit about what I mean here.
So here, let's imagine we take
the original input and then
the generated output, which
is trying to be that input.
So what we're trying to do
is to see is, let's say,
we take a given patch that
is in the same location
in both images.
What we're trying to do
is whether the two have
the same overall structure.
And what I mean by that
is, do the colors have
the same intensity?
Does it have the
same brightness?
The second one can be, does
it have the same contrast?
And so here we can think of
the variance in pixel values
within that patch.
And the third one
is, do pixels vary
in the same fashion in the first
patch and in the second patch?
So these are the three
dimensions we care about.
And for each of
them, the first one
would be around computing the
mean of the pixels in the patch
in order to quantify
the brightness,
or the color intensity
of the patch.
The second one,
the contrast would
be around quantifying how
much these pixels vary,
so you can very well take
the variance of those pixels.
And then the third one is
regarding the structure,
and here, you can very well take
the covariance between these two
patches.
And what you will get when you
compare the two is a similarity
quantity that here in
the luminance case,
takes in the mean
of the first patch
and the mean of
the second patch,
and tries to make a
number out of them.
So is it the first time
you're seeing this formula?
Yeah?
I don't want it for this
to be looking scary.
So if you're looking at
the formula, what you see
is there are two quantities,
so let's note them A and B,
in this case.
And you have something 2AB
over A squared plus B squared.
So you also have a constant that
is just for stability purposes,
just in case both of them are 0.
But in this case, you can assume
that A and B are greater than 0.
So what can you say
about this quantity?
So from high school, you may
remember that you have this very
general identity, which is as
follows, so A minus B squared,
which is a squared minus
2AB plus B squared.
Well, here you can rewrite this
as A squared plus B squared,
minus A minus B squared, over
A squared plus B squared.
So I'm going to
replace in place.
And so here what I'm going to
say is that this is equal to 1.
I need to say here this is
equal to 1 minus this quantity.
And here, this is positive,
so this is bounded by 1.
And A is positive,
B is positive.
This quantity is positive.
This is bounded by 0.
So this is a coefficient
that is between 0 and 1.
This is what I'm trying to say.
So here, if A and B are
similar, so if A is equal to B,
this is equal to 0.
It's equal to 1.
So what I'm trying
to say is this metric
is a similarity metric that
you may read on the papers.
It's called the
Dice coefficient.
And the reason why
it's a good metric
is because it gives you the
similarity of two quantities
by considering also the
values that they're at.
So I'm going to illustrate
it with an example.
So this quantity, so if
let's say, A is equal to 10
and B is equal to 20, then
let's say that quantity
that I'm going to let's say d.
d for Dice coefficient.
So that d will be equal
to 0.8, if you compute it.
But if A is equal to
100 and B is equal to,
let's say, 110, then d is
going to be much closer to 1.
And B maybe something
somewhere around 0.995.
So I computed this before
the lecture, so don't worry.
I'm not hallucinating things.
But here, what I want
to say is that this idea
of considering the
level that you're at
and considering the relative
difference with respect
to where you're at, which
we saw with the logarithm
and with the light bulb
story, is also something
that is captured here.
So even though A and
B are 10 apart, here,
they are less similar than here.
So all of that to say
that I hope that when
you look at this
formula, it doesn't
look as something that
came out of the blue.
So in this formula
on the slide, we're
using this way of
computing similarity using
the mean of the
pixels, which gives you
the luminance similarity.
You can do the
same for contrast,
so here you use the variance
and the standard deviation.
And you also have one
for the structure.
Well, this one is a
little bit different.
You're actually using
the Pearson correlation,
which gives you a quantity
that is between minus 1 and 1.
So let's assume you've
done that for luminance,
for contrast, for structure.
And just for simplicity,
let's note them L, C,
and S. What we're doing is we're
just multiplying everything.
So if things are similar,
they're equal to 1.
If things are not similar,
then L is more equal to 0,
C is tending to 0, and
S, the correlation,
is tending to minus 1.
And so this is exactly
what we mentioned.
And as a result, you are
getting this formula, which
you may have seen in textbooks.
It looks really scary when
you just look at this formula
firsthand, but with this
way of looking at things,
I hope it will not
look scary anymore.
And so if you do that
operation for all patches,
and the resulting
metric that you obtain
is the average of those
scores across your patches.
And you get a metric that
is called the SSIM, so
the Structural SIMilarity,
which is a score between minus 1
and 1, where the closer you
are to 1, the more similar
the images should be from
a structural perspective.
But you may tell me,
well, it's on patches.
What if your shift
is beyond the patch?
And I would say, yeah,
you're completely right.
This metric, although
being less pixel-dependent
than the MSC and
the PSNR is still
sensitive to that
pixel shift, which
is the reason why there
is a final metric I want
to talk to you about, which
we actually have already
seen in lecture, I believe,
4, which is the LPIPS,
the Learned Perceptual
Image Patch Similarity.
And that one is
actually quite simple.
Instead of comparing your x with
your x hat in the pixel space,
what you do is you
take each quantity,
and you let them through
a pre-trained encoder.
And you compute
the representation
that this encoder
has, which tells
you more about how
perceptually similar they are,
as opposed to exactly
how aligned they
are from a pixel perspective.
And so here, you
have this distance
between phi Lx and phi Lx hat.
So the L represents the layer
of that pre-trained encoder.
And you also have
a coefficient w,
which is actually
a coefficient that
was determined such that
the resulting metric aligns
with human perception.
So I believe, these
were tunes because there
was a data set of images.
And the idea was
to tune this metric
so that it's as aligned
as possible with
the human perception levels.
And that metric is actually
quite commonly used,
and so you may see
it quite often.
The only problem to call
out, only top of mind,
is that it's not super
interpretable in terms
of what is going wrong.
So if your metric
is not doing great,
you need to see what's going on.
And that was it.
Any questions before-- yep.
So the question is for this last
one, which pre-trained model is
there to use?
So I believe it is VGG.
So there's AlexNet as well.
The reason why we have
some preset encoders
is because the coefficients Wl
are dependent on the encoder
that you use.
So you can use the
libraries and mention
which encoder you
want to leverage,
but typically, it's
either VGG or AlexNet.
So the question is, what
does the formula mean?
So within the distance,
what you have is two terms.
One is the difference
between the feature map
of x and feature map of x hat.
And you multiply
that elementwise
with the coefficient Wl.
Does that make sense?
Perfect.
So the question is this
was for two images.
How do you apply
it to the batch?
So just as a reminder,
we're looking
at cases where we care
about how good of a job
we did about
reconstructing an input.
So what you care about
is how far off you are.
And so this metric tells
you how far off you
are in trying to
reconstruct an input,
and so if you want
to aggregate, you
can use the traditional
aggregations
like mean and so on.
Cool.
Great.
With that, I'll
give it to Shervin.
Thank you, Afshin.
So exactly as we saw,
all of these metrics,
they're very mathematical,
and what we want
is have a way to interpret them
from an intuition standpoint.
So we saw that all
these metrics, they
were operating at
different levels
and there are many of them.
So what I'm going to do is
invite you to do a little detour
and visit a class of models
that we call multi-modal LLMs,
because they have
the nice property
of being able to convert text
and image data in a text.
But before we do that,
let's do a little summary
of the kinds of models we've
seen so far in the class.
So we saw the
transformer at some point
that we know
transforms bits of text
to text, so this
is not something
that we can use out of the box.
We saw DIT, where based on
latent noise and potentially
a condition, you could
generate an image.
So here, it's a
generation of images.
This is also a model that
we cannot reuse as is.
And same for MMDIT,
where the input was
guided by potentially
texts, not just a condition.
And here, we're in
this sibling problem
of dealing with both
modalities, except that we
want image and text
at the input in order
to find a way to judge them
and get text as output.
So this is typically the setup
that we're interested in,
so we have a model.
We have a picture, let's
say, here a teddy bear,
and we ask a question that
would guide the evaluation.
So let's say, how cute
is this teddy bear?
And you would want such
an evaluation model
to give you the answer.
So before starting
all of this, I just
want to make the problem
a bit more concrete.
What do we have at hand?
So when we talk
about images and when
we talk about text, what we can
do is convert them to tokens.
And at the end of
the day, tokens,
they're just
embeddings, so we're
facing the problem of trying
to find an architecture that
can accept these
embeddings and turn them
into interpretable text.
So one thing that comes
to mind-- so if you recall
the architecture
of the transformer,
let's say you have
a text-based model.
One natural choice
could be to leverage
that cross-attention
layer that could
enable you to make text tokens,
attend to anything you want.
And that anything you
want, the keys and values
of cross-attention could
very well be images.
So this is one
possible direction,
where you use text tokens
as input of your decoder,
and then you keep this cross
attention mechanism in order
to make it interact
with encoded images.
So this is something
that people have
done because it's a very
natural thing to do,
and it's also quite efficient
computationally because you
leverage a fixed context
length only composed of texts,
and then you make it
interact with images.
So there is one example
here that we can
cite of a model that did so.
So Flamingo by
Google, where images
are given as keys and values,
and you have some placeholder
token that gates when it's
fine to attend to these images.
So this is one possibility.
But one caveat of this mindset
is that you cannot directly
leverage the latest advances
in large language models
because as you know, these
are decoder only models,
and they have gotten rid of
that cross-attention altogether,
so you cannot use all these
latest models that have been
tuned and work great
out of the box.
You need to re-engineer that
cross-attention layer in there.
So this is why you
see a second branch
of dealing with
multi-modal input, which
is to directly feed this image
and text tokens as input.
And one example of
such model is a LLaVA.
So here, you use an encoder
to find the right embedding
for those tokens for image
patches like a VAT model,
and then you give it to
that decoder-only structure.
Great.
And these days,
exactly for the reason
that I mentioned like
quality, but also
the fact of reusing wins,
this latter technique
is what people use in practice.
So all the latest MLLM
that you might see
are based oftentimes
on putting both images
and text as input
of the decoder,
not doing cross attention.
And they have some capabilities
that I'm mentioning here.
We're not going to go
into details about them,
but I want you to
be aware of them
because we're going to
actively use them at the time
we want to use these
models for judging.
So one is a working with
all kinds of images.
So there's a question here.
So the question is, what do you
mean by reuse existing wins?
So it's an engineering question.
You could definitely reuse
something already trained
like have weights frozen
and start from there.
This is one possibility.
I was more thinking about an
architectural standpoint, where
you have a design that
is proven to work.
This is just another
modality with a same input
that you can just
recycle, but then
on how you actually come
up with such a model,
it's more of an
engineering problem.
So I don't give a
specific opinion on it,
but I do think you
could definitely
initialize weights and reuse it
in the strict sense of the term.
So we want these
models to be working
across all kinds of inputs.
And in particular,
one property that you
want your generative
models is to generate text
as part of your images.
So let's say if you want to
generate the image of a sign,
you want the text
to be readable,
so you would want
models that do judge
this kind of generated images
to be aware of characters.
So this is why I mentioned OCR.
And then also one other thing
which I think was mentioned here
is we do not want to have a
black box that just gives us
a number.
We want to have some rationale
behind what grades that we give,
so this is why leveraging
reasoning abilities
of such models is going to be
something that we want to use.
Great.
So now, I want us to look
at traditional metrics
and then find some of
the key concerns we had
and see what could be
ways to mitigate them.
So one thing that
we were concerned
with with traditional metrics
was that you get a number,
but at the end of the day,
you don't what to do with it.
Let's say you have a prompt
that gave a given image
and you have a
certain CLIP score.
Now what do you do with it?
So this is something that you
could fix by taking the prompt
and trying to reason
about what properties
in the generated image
could make it such
that the image would
match the prompt?
And this is something
that you could
do by decomposing what you care
about into atomic properties.
This is what the
TIFA paper does,
so Text-to-Image
Faithfulness Evaluation,
where they use few shot learning
to show examples of what
interesting decompositions of
what you care about in an image
might look like.
And they apply it
to a given prompt
to generate a set of
questions, and these questions
are very simple.
They're just yes or no, or
things where the answer is
obviously right or wrong.
So that way you
decompose the judging
into dimensions that
are quite quantitative.
And what you do is that
you take MLLM model
to assess each of these
dimensions independently.
So for example here, this
teddy bear reading a book.
Is it a teddy bear?
So yes.
Is it cute?
Yes.
Is there a book?
And is the Teddy bear
reading the book?
Yes as well.
So such a metric
would give you a score
that matches the fact that all
of these criteria were met.
And it's quite
interesting because
in the case of CLIP
score, even though you
have an image that semantically
matches your input prompt,
you're not exactly sure what
that remaining delta is about.
And with the method that
decomposes these concerns,
you could pinpoint
what goes wrong.
So it's quite simple,
and you could debug
where the issue comes from.
But on the other
hand, this method
of generating dimensions
that you care about per image
is quite bespoke
because you're here.
At every prompt that
you input your data set,
you need to have a
grading rubric that
is specific to that prompt.
So the fact of generating
that rubric in the first place
is going to be expensive,
and it might be error prone.
And something else is that you
have all of these questions that
examine multiple
sides of that prompt,
but the weighing of
each of these claims
might not match the
importance of what each
claim to your point of view.
So, for example, here, if
you don't have a book at all,
then you might have one
or two that goes away.
And you would have maybe
half of the metric that--
the metric would be about
half of the max score,
but it necessarily might
not be what you want,
so you might want a way
to generate a rubric that
is more robust to that.
I'm going to take a
pause for a few seconds
and see if that makes sense.
OK, awesome.
So I'm going to state
another complaint.
So here we saw CLIP score.
And one great thing
about CLIP score
is that it can try to convey
whether the semantic meaning
of a generated
image was preserved.
But one thing that we observe
is that semantically encoding
the meaning of a
prompt within a vector,
and then doing some dot products
with respect to the embedding
of the image, might not carry
all the semantic subtleties
that prompt variations
might convey.
So here, one thing that
we observe in practice
is that in the cute bear reading
a book example, if you exchange
book and teddy bear from
a semantic perspective
like to your intuition, it
changes things quite a bit.
You would have a totally
another image in mind.
But from a CLIP
score standpoint,
it turns out that the score
doesn't change that much.
So you could explain
this by the fact
that you're projecting
all of the image
and all of the content of
the prompt into vectors,
and these are not very richly
conveying all these subtleties.
But also one other explanation
could reside in the way
that CLIP is trained,
because you are incentivized
to match images and prompts in
a way that matches those that
correspond with respect
to text image captions
but you have this concept
of in batch negatives
that we saw at the time, where
we introduced CLIP, where you
try to make the
distance between images
and prompts that have
nothing to do with that image
further apart, so
you don't really
have an incentive to
learn these subtleties.
And these are the two main
reasons why CLIP score is not
that great.
But you might tell me OK.
Hey, Shervin, CLIP was
generated with the embedding
of the entire sentence
because, as we remember,
you would encode the meaning of
a given sentence with a decoder,
and then extract the
last embedding, which
contains the embedding
of the whole sentence.
So one thing we can do
is have the same property
with the trick, where you input
both the image and the sentence
in the same embedding, and
then extract the probability
of whether both image and
sentence are supposed to match
or not.
So this is something that
is called VQA score, where
the template is very simple.
So you always follow
this same structure
where you put the image.
And then you ask
yourself, does this figure
show and the content
of your prompt?
And then what you do is that
you look at your probability
distribution of your
next token, and you
look at the one that
corresponds to the token yes.
And you say that
that probability
is going to be your score, which
means that if the sentence is
semantically similar or
matching to the image,
you're going to have a high
probability and lower otherwise.
So by doing so, you can
alleviate this issue
that we had seen at the CLIP
score level, where you were
comparing vectors
in a coarse fashion,
and now you're directly
reusing the structure
of the decoded output in
order to embed both modalities
in a way that makes sense.
So the question, can
a regular LLM do it?
So very pedantically,
no, because you
have image modality in there.
But let's say the
question is for MLLM.
Can a standard MLLM do it?
So we advocate that yes,
because it is trained yet
to understand broader concepts,
so its a zero shot task.
So yeah.
So that's a great point.
It emphasizes one benefit
of this technique.
You do not need to train
anything in a bespoke manner.
You just take an
off the shelf MLLM
that does know how
to understand things.
OK great.
But one drawback
that you might notice
is that this technique
relies on you having access
to the probability
distribution of the next token.
And if you take all the
latest and best models
out there that might
be closed source,
they do not disclose the
probability distribution
of the next token.
If you are in the
field of distillation,
you know it's a
very sensitive topic
because you can learn a
lot of things from it,
so this is not something
that you have access to.
And something else
that is wasteful
is every time you
ask such questions,
you need to do a
dedicated MLLM call,
and these are quite expensive.
So from a user standpoint,
you could say, OK fine,
I have a provider, I will
do all of them in parallel
and wait for the
max of all of them
to finish to have my
result, which is not
that bad oftentimes,
but it's quite costly
as it scales with the number
of decomposed dimensions.
And everything that
I've mentioned here
is focusing on the
prompts of your data set.
So you're inferring your
conditions and dimensions
above the prompt
of the data set.
There seems like a
better way to do it.
You're still stuck in
these ancient worlds,
where you try to engineer
everything, even metrics.
You try to engineer them in
order to make sense of them
afterwards.
But one shift of paradigm
that seems attractive here
is instead of being
prompt-centric,
be concept-centric of what
you consider to be good,
and then describe that
good in a generic way.
And then leverage all of
the reasoning capabilities
of these MLLM models to do
that reasoning on your behalf
and come up with
the final score.
So does everyone agree that
this strategy sounds attractive?
Great.
And this brings
us to a paper that
popularized this
mindset called VIEScore,
so Visual Instruction-guided
Explainable Score, where
you give your prompt, you
give your generated image,
and then you describe a rubric.
And Afshin, if you remember at
the beginning of the lecture,
he mentioned two axes, where
we broadly had an interest in.
So one is semantic
consistency, and the other one
is perceptual quality.
And these efforts formalizes
how we could write rubrics
and grades for both of them.
So you would have such a rubric,
and then ask an MLLM about it.
And then since this
task is about judging,
you call such a model
MLLM-as-a-Judge.
And the good thing
about these models
is that they are
interpretable, and you
can ask them to output some
reasoning before prompting them
for a given score, which
is what this paper does.
And with our two dimensions
that we care about, so
semantic consistency
and perceptual quality,
respectively denoting whether
the image follows the prompt
and whether the
image looks good.
So you could have two different
generations and you might smile
at the second one because
it's not very realistic,
which is why you might-- so
it's technically still reading
the book on the right-hand side,
but on the natural aspects,
this is where an MLLM-as-a-Judge
might come in and just keep us
in check.
Great.
And just formalizing the fact of
asking about an MLLM-as-a-Judge
opinion regarding grading
a given dimension.
So typically, what
you would have
is that you first
give your input
and then you handcraft a set
of guidelines with respect
to each of the
dimensions of interest.
And then you ask your
MLLM-as-a-Judge to output its
decision in some given format.
One that is popular is
JSON, because you can then
parse scores and rationales
and anything else
that you care about
in a structured way
by just accessing fields.
And one question
that comes to mind
is how to ensure that the
rationales and the scores
actually do make sense.
So here comes the
most interesting part
of the lecture, which is once
you have a problem, where you
have a judge that you want
to use to grade your images,
how are you going to make them
aligned with what you as a human
find good?
So this is the first
stage, where you
would take in a true setting.
You would take your
prompts, you would
take your generated images,
and you would typically
ask humans to grade them
alongside the rubrics
of interest.
So let's say, you have
perceptual quality and semantic
consistency, you would first get
a sense of what is good versus
bad from a human standpoint.
And the second step would
be to handcraft rubrics that
would match human intuition.
So these days, handcraft
it's a bit of a strong word
because you wouldn't
actually handcraft this.
You would ask a model to
handcraft instructions
that would be such that
the resulting ratings would
match human intuition.
And once you have that,
then you can further
judge other prompts image
pairs with that trained judge.
So this is a three stage
way of solving this problem.
So first, just
asking your intuition
about what is good, then tuning
the MLLMs rubrics about it,
and then third one
would be directly asking
the MLLM about new images.
And so you might have
multiple settings,
where you would ask for advice.
So you have a pointwise
setting, where
you have a given
image, a given prompt,
and you want to know
if the result is good.
You have the pairwise setting
that Afshin also mentioned,
and you have another one
where you have a prompt,
you have a list of images, and
you want the model to rank them.
So going one by one.
In practice, pointwise
is great when
you want to do one-sided
evaluation of your images.
So just to have a rough idea,
but also to debug what goes well
versus doesn't go well,
because as you remember,
you have this rationale side of
the MLLM-as-a-Judge output that
can guide you towards
understanding loss modes
of your model.
So it can either lead to
you iterating on the image
generation model, or coming back
to the calibration of the judge
itself, because it might not
correspond to the intuition
that you have in mind, so it's
great for doing both of them.
Another setting is
the pairwise one,
which is great when you want to
compare models with each other.
So typically, if you have a
new iteration of the model
and you want to know if it's
fine to replace it altogether,
you would use this kind of mode.
And then regarding
ranking, even though that's
something that's
studied in papers,
it's typically not
used in practice
because the ordering
might be too sensitive,
and so you have a
lot of variants.
And oftentimes, the
ranking of several outputs
might not be something that you
want to do as a one shot task,
so it might not have as
broad applications as the two
other ones.
So I just want to spend a few
minutes to talk about best
practices overall when you
deal with MLLM-as-a-Judge.
So here, we saw with VIEScore
that you could decompose
what you care about into two
dimensions, but in real life,
you might have use cases, where
you have a task-specific rubric
that is not general, but that
might be specific to what
you care about.
So you would typically
decompose and isolate
that as a separate
metric and make
the judging be done on all
these sets of criteria,
including that
other one that would
be designed to be atomic and
isolating what you care about.
So another thing is that
empirically, you typically want
your model to output the
rationale before outputting
a score, because
in the LLM space,
you have all this research
around concepts surrounding
chains of thoughts and how
it improves the performance.
And the intuition
for it is that even
as a human, when you want to
form an opinion on something,
it's always good to
enumerate facts about it.
Just say out loud
what you have in mind
when you do a piece of
judgment before actually
doing the judgment.
So this is a good practice.
Something else is
that with LLMs, you
have this temperature parameter
that controls how creative
and how deterministic versus
stochastic your output gets.
And typically, when
you use chatbots,
these are not set to zero.
So outputs are typically
non-deterministic
because quality is
typically better when
it's non-deterministic
for a range of tasks,
but for very precise
tasks like judgments,
where when you are grounded
on the input that you're given
and the rubrics
that you're given,
this is typically a use case
where it's fine to make it set
to zero, and also because
you want determinism across
your MLLM-as-a-Judge runs.
Something else is that you
might see position bias, if you
are in a pairwise
setting, so it's
good to swap the ordering
of the two samples
that you want to compare.
And the last point is something
that we mentioned just before.
We want to make sure it's
aligned with human judgment
before actually going ahead
and then trusting it blindly.
So I want to spend the
last 5 minutes talking
about the main
benchmarks that cover
some of the characteristics
that we care about
on image generation.
So on benchmarks, I
will go through points
that cover overall areas
that we care about.
So one is, let's say
you have a prompt.
You want to make sure
that whatever is generated
contains the objects
and some high level
attributes that you
mentioned in your prompt.
So this is where GenEval,
it's one possible benchmark,
comes to mind, where you have
a six tasks of increasing
difficulty that
talks about objects
like counting of objects,
colors of objects,
and relative position, as
well as attribution of colors.
So the judges here are
object detection models
that will come in
and then detect
whether the right objects or
the right colors were generated,
so this is one example.
So you have a photo of a purple
backpack and a white umbrella,
and you want to make sure that
both objects and colors are
correctly attributed.
And something else that
you care about that
might touch on something
that you mentioned.
So when you deal
with dense prompts,
so typically, prompts
that are very detailed,
you want to make sure
that all of the details
are correctly rendered.
And this is why these
DPG bench benchmark
has a mechanism that looks a bit
like what we saw in TIFA, where
you have this big chunk
of text that you decompose
into a set of atomic
yes or no questions.
And the interesting
thing about this paper
is that it groups all of
these claims into a graph
that is logical.
So here, you have
a big chunk of text
and it decomposes
into questions that
are centered on
attributes, relationships,
and spatial location.
And let's say you want to
judge about a given attribute,
so here, that's
long bunch of texts
mentions like an empty space,
where an invisible man has
this and that.
So first, you need the
empty space to exist.
And this benchmark looks at it
in a coarse to fine mindset.
So if the prerequisite
doesn't exist,
then you don't even bother
looking at the other conditions,
so this is what makes this
benchmark interestingly
efficient.
And conversely, if one
precondition exists,
then you move on to the
next pieces of the graph.
So this is another area.
So something else that we had
mentioned regarding capabilities
that we were interested in
was OCR as a capability.
And on the image
generation side,
you might want to
generate images
that have walls
of text in there,
and you want to know how
well they are rendered.
So there is a long
text bench that
could be mentioned,
where you have scenarios,
where displaying
text might be seen
as interesting from an image
generation perspective.
And the paper uses a VLM,
typically an OCR judge,
that will try to render the
text in the generated image,
and it will match to the
reference text that was
used as a generation prompt.
And if both match, then
we say that the text
was correctly
generated, so it's one
other interesting application.
And then the last
one I will mention
is on another image
generation mode
that is of interest,
typically, when
you want to generate an image.
So if you want to operate
on top of a given image.
So here, Grounded Edits Bench.
So I put a question mark
because it's not explicitly
spelled out in the paper,
but the abbreviation meaning,
but the grounding part is on
the input image that is given.
So you ask a task
about it, for example,
replacing some background,
changing colors, and so on.
So you have 11 such tasks, and
you use a MLLM-as-a-Judge model
that operates on both perceptual
quality and semantic consistency
to judge the output.
So here's a figure from their
paper on what it looks like.
And I just want to say one
last word about all of this.
Sometimes you might
be overwhelmed
with all these metrics.
So we saw at the
beginning of the lecture,
a bunch of quantitative ones.
We saw MLLM-as-a-Judge ones that
are still imperfect because they
depend on how well you tune
it, so there is no absolute way
of knowing how
something performs.
And you might be prone to only
relying on a few sample images
as a way to who have an opinion
about a given image model,
but I want to say that so
let's do the following thought
experiment.
If you consider
not the procedure
of picking the next image that
is generated by your model,
but the best of three, versus
the least well of three,
then you see the
corresponding distributions
are quite different.
So from the same image
generation model,
you could handcraft
different distributions just
by the way you go
about sampling what
you want to display to someone.
So yeah, I just
want to put a caveat
on when you see images doesn't
tell the whole story either.
And with that, thank you
very much for coming here,
despite the long weekend.
I hope you have a great one.
[APPLAUSE]